hey guys and thank you so much for
joining me for this session and today we
are going to talk about how to break
into apis
we'll talk about modern techniques to
break into modern applications that are
based on apis
so the agenda for today is first of all
before we even talk about application
security and about how you can leverage
apis to hack into applications
basically to understand what is modern
application security and how it's
different
than traditional application security
after we talk about it we will cover uh
some of the hosts top 10 free apis with
emphasize of how to leverage these
issues as the fantastic and how you can
use the os top 10 for apis to find cool
vulnerabilities and to break apis
and then we'll see some recent examples
for api issues that happen in the last
few months in large companies
so i want to talk in a very high level
like briefly about what has changed
between
traditional applications and modern
applications so here on the top of the
screen you can see the traffic patterns
between the client web server and
database in the case of traditional
applications
in the past it used to be pretty simple
the client would send an http call to
fetch one specific web page for example
home.jsp and then the web server would
fetch data from the database in order to
build
the visual component the visual web page
that will be sent back to the client
this process of converting the data into
like a visual page is called rendering
so the rendering component was on the
web server and then the web server
simply returned an html page to the
client would be presented to the user by
the browser
today things look very differently first
of all
the clients
know much better what they want the
clients don't ask for a complete web
page they ask for specific pieces of
information for example if you are
looking at a dashboard component of some
application the client would send api
calls to fetch the last 20 notification
or fetch the top 10 users as part of
this app
so clients have much more context of
what they need and what they want
and also it's it's worth to mention
that
today clients maintain the user state
back in the day you had mechanisms on
the back end so the backend knew exactly
what is the state of the user what what
buttons the user has clicked what is the
specific state of the user it was done
using
view states and cookies and other
mechanisms today in apis and modern
applications usually the clients
maintain this state and the web server
has less context of what is happening on
the client side
um so after the web server gets the
calls from the clients it will fetch
data from the database and you have more
types of databases in top of like the
traditional sql you can find today
elastic and nosql
and many more other types of databases
and then another interesting change you
know instead of returning html pages to
date the web server the api returns raw
data in the format of json
so the client would just receive raw
data and all the rendering process the
creation of the visual page we've done
would be done on the client itself this
is a very interesting change
a few other changes is first of all
you have more types of clients on top of
the traditional web servers you can find
iot devices mobile devices and sometimes
even other developers that use your apis
to develop their own applications
the second point which is very
interesting
i had this claim many times that apis
have less abstraction layers
it has many different aspects there is
no one
concept that supports this you know
claim but one important one important
concept is that apis
today the clients the apis and the
servers they speak the same language all
of them speak in json for example
the receipt object that your
google client is processing on your
mobile device might be the same json
object on the api and sometimes even on
the databases so there is much less
passing when it comes to like objects
that are sent from the client because
all of them speak the same language
in terms of application security
it's uh was to mention that many of the
traditional web application
vulnerabilities like
are being solved today
and for example if we talk about sql
injections many of them are solved by
the use of orm environments by
developers if we talk about csrf today
it's much less common because developers
move from a cookies to authorization
header if your authentication mechanism
is not based on cookies you are not
vulnerable to csrf by design
crossover scripting to dates the
responsibility of the client to protect
you against cost encrypting
apis return raw data in the form of json
they don't return any html pages so this
is why it's the responsibility of the
client
if we talked about xxc for example which
is a vulnerability in the passing
process of xmls today it's less common
because developers use jsons and they
don't really pass xmls
let's move to the bad news
so the first point about apis
you know many times when i see a rest
apis that is exposed by a company that
i'm performing a pen test to i get very
excited apis today has a very attractive
target for attackers
and there are many reasons but i think
the main ones are first of all the
attack surface is much larger
apis expose more endpoints and apis
receive more parameters
in order to support the same component
for example in the case of
of the dashboard component in the case
of traditional applications you would
see only one entry point to get
dashboard in the case of modern
applications you might see five
different endpoints that are being used
to populate data for the same exact
component
and the second point is apis are
oversharing you can take a look at the
traffic between the clients and the api
and to understand the underlying
implementation of the application
and the third point is that apis are
much more predictable
and the rest standard and the graphql
standard encourage developers to develop
apis in a very predictable way
it's very convenient for the front-end
engineers to use these apis but it also
makes satakis life much easier
to
to guess a sensitive api at an endpoint
for example admin endpoints
so all of these changes that i've seen
made me join areas alone and to start
the os top 10 for api's project and in
general the os
api security project
we
tried to define this modern battleground
it was a very interesting process to
create this list
uh we collected a lot of data from a bug
bounties programs and then we came up
with the final list of the os top 10 and
we also got a bunch of feedback from the
community to prioritize and to add new
vulnerabilities
so i want to talk with you about api
processing
this is the main goal of the
presentation to to give you some ideas
and some tips how to perform a better
api pen testing
um
so it's not only a bunch of tips it's
also like i'm gonna talk about the
required mindset in order to hack apis
let's let's talk about some of these
concepts
first of all
in my opinion there are two types of
panzers the one the first type is more
straightforward you just try to break
into an application you you generate a
payload you try to like exploit sql
injection and stuff like that
sometimes you get vulnerability
sometimes you don't
this is like the most the most simple
approach to perform a pen test and then
the second approach is to get into the
developer mind like i think every
experience fantastic will tell you if
you want to exploit and to find cool
vulnerabilities in the application that
you are testing you need to understand
what happens on the back end even if we
talk about black box and you don't have
access to the code you should aspire to
understand what happens on the back end
so how can you read developers minds to
understand what they wrote on the code
um so there are a few things you can do
the first one you should think like a
developer and in order to do it it's
really helpful to know how to code i
think that every good fantastic that
wants to find business logic
vulnerabilities needs to understand code
you don't need to be the best developer
i promise you i'm not a great developer
i don't know all the design patterns and
you know i usually don't leave lots of
comments in my code but i do understand
code and i do know how to code simple
scripts and i think it's very important
for you as a pen tester to do it if you
want to find cool stuff
and the third point is to understand the
dna of the app the dna of the app would
allow you to understand better the
business logic of the app and
it's very important to understand that
today when you talk about api
vulnerabilities many of them are based
on business logic business logic abuse
of the application so in order to
to abuse the business logic you need to
understand the business logic
so
as i told you about three years ago i
moved to california and one of the
coolest concepts that i found one of the
coolest things i found after i moved is
mindfulness
and a mindfulness make you a better
person but it also can make you a better
a better pen tester so there are many
concepts from mindfulness that you can
leverage in api is fantastic first of
all is beginner's mind beginner's mind
is a concept that tells you that you
need to be curious about anything in
life so the same thing about apis you
should understand what is the business
logic of the application by looking at
the api traffic and many times i know
that pentesters if they see api
endpoints they don't understand they
just ignore it or they just assume that
it's not important this is not a good
approach when it comes to pen testing
for api every time that you see an api
endpoint you should understand at least
what is the purpose of the api endpoint
and to ask meaningful questions what is
the feature that caused this api called
to trigger
and stuff like that
and the second point
you should win yourself of gui many
times when you perform a pen test for
apis you don't have a client or the
client doesn't access all the features
so and you have only documentation for
the api you should you shouldn't let
phil stop you from generating api calls
from scratch you know just to to start
understanding how you can call an api
endpoint without having an active client
um so do you know what all these
companies have in common uber facebook
and shopify
they all got breached in the last year
because of access control problems it
leads me to the point that authorization
problems is the biggest threat of apis
every company has authorization
problems so
most of the api vulnerabilities are
somehow related to utilization and i
want to spend some time talking about it
so the most common api vulnerability er
ebola
it's broken object of virtualization
this is you probably know this when the
build is either insecure direct object
reference
uh it's basically a vulnerability that
allows you to access ids that belong to
other users in this case i'm trying to
download document my client would send
an api call to download number to
download file number one one three
which is legit because this is a file
that belongs to me but then i just
change the id from 113 to 114 and i
access a file from a different user
number three exceptional data exposure
it's another type of authorization
problem uh this this happens because the
developers return too much information
to the user so the client just returned
too much information and number five
broken functional virtualization these
are api endpoints that should be
accessed only by admins or privileges
users but the developers don't check
the
if the user that's called the api
endpoint
is actually an admin
i want to talk about the dna of modern
applications those are the building
corks of the business logic and if you
want to have a more comprehensive
fantast you need to understand them you
need to understand them like in a mental
way just just to understand in your mind
or sometimes it's also helpful to write
down and to create some diagrams when
you perform printers to understand what
are the components let's talk about some
of this dna
some of these build is building rocks of
apis
so if we take for example the uber
application you have different types of
users and roles you have riders drivers
and admins and you need to understand
what are the different clients of uber
you have a mobile which is obvious you
have um like android and ios then you
have your application i'm not sure if
you know but you can access google also
using your application which is a
different api and you also have iot so
in the case of uber you have a e-scooter
for example all the jump bikes they
communicate with the uber api
using a different api and then you need
to understand what are the different
apis behind the scenes and the resources
in the case of uber the resources will
be the receipts the trips the users and
scooters for example
if you understand this full picture it
would be much easier for you to
understand the business logic and to
expand our taxes
so let's talk about broken object
levelization
which is idle and how we can exploit it
and more than that how we can
leverage the dna of the application in
order to perform better exploitation and
to find more potentially vulnerable
endpoints
so let's say that you after the photo to
the good application you have a feature
of apple in your photo and then you see
that if you want to access this photo
there is an api call to get slash editor
api slash v1 slash photos 717
so if we translate it to business logic
you can tell yourself that there is a
resource that is exposed to an api to me
let's try to see what are these
components so a resource
is a photo
and then the api
is the editor api you can see it in the
url
and me who is me i am the user bob which
the user id of 8581 i'm a regular user
and i'm accessing this api endpoint
using the mobile application this is an
ios application
so
this is if you translate this api
endpoint like if you just perform a
simple pen test you would just try to
change the idea from seven one seven to
seven one six and you might get the
access to a photo
to photo of someone else or just follow
one like to get rejected but let's see
how we can leverage this language of the
dna of the api in order to to expand
attack surface and to find more
potential endpoints are vulnerable to
ebola
so some question that you you should ask
yourself regarding the resource
regarding the photo
first of all
is the resource private sometimes we can
see api endpoints that receive ideas but
even if you try to change the id to
something else you can get access to a
different id
it's not necessarily a vulnerability
because sometimes these resources are
public for example it's a news article
everyone should have access to this
endpoint so make sure that you don't
send bugs that contain idols for
resources that are private
the second question you can ask yourself
is is the resource shareable is it
possible to share the resource sometimes
if you have on facebook for example an
option to share a photo with someone
else it can lead to another
vulnerabilities
and the last question
is the resource encapsulated what does
it mean so let's say that you try to
find bola to steal photos of other users
but you can't you can't really find any
api endpoints that is vulnerable to
bowler bola it access photos
the next thing that i will try to do is
to find what resources might contain the
photo so in the use case it might be an
album
and then you can expand your attack
surface
and uh
you should list all the api endpoints
the text that
access
the resource or the encapsulated
resource
let's see how we can do it for example
what we can do is to change the editor
api slash v1 to elito api slash v0 this
is a different api input is potentially
vulnerable to ball
and then uh
if we did if we see that all the
endpointed access photos don't want to
bola let's try to move to the um
let's try to move to export album
to like to an endpoint that actually
access the almond the album behind the
scenes and only if you have the
understanding that the album contains
photos you can you can be more focused
on this api endpoint that expose the
album
and then you can start asking yourself
can i use a different client to access
the same resource can i use a different
maybe if i access the web application
would it look different well if i access
mobile the mobile api it would look
different so many times if you have web
web client or a mobile client
the api endpoints that they trigger the
api calls that they trigger belongs to
different endpoints so you might have
one endpoint to get photo for mobile and
one
endpoint to get photo for web and you
should
test both of them
so if you have if you like you map all
the endpoints that might be vulnerable
to bola
to to
and your goal is to access a photo of
someone else how can you validate that
the specific endpoint is vulnerable so
there are a few approaches many times
what pentesters prefer to do is just
should change the id of 717 to an id of
something else for example 716
but
there is a better way to do it
so the first step would be to create
user number one to log into the api and
to create a photo and then to access
this photo so you access a folder that
belongs to you this is nothing exciting
but you need to have this api call
documented for example on fiddler or
burp
and then what you do is create a
different user
and
you copy the session label of this user
after you log in to this user b that you
just created you need to create to copy
the session enable a session label what
is a session label is basically every
string that is used by the api to
identify a user it can be authentication
token it can be a session id it can be
everything else it doesn't really matter
you just need to copy this single string
that is used by the api to the different
user and to duplicate the first request
to access photo seven one seven and to
replace the
session label and after you do it if you
get
if you get access to the photo it means
that the second user could have gotten
access to the photo and it's vulnerable
to bowler if you got some authorization
error like follow one or four three it's
probably not vulnerable
some random tricks to ebola
and sometimes you can see that
companies have implemented authorization
mechanisms but it's still possible to
bypass them
some ways to do it is first of all you
can try to wrap the id with an array
sometimes the input filtering or the
authorization checks are done only for
integers but not for arrays that contain
integers you can try to send the url the
id twice in the url for example in this
api endpoint
the id the first id would be the legit
and then the second one would be the
victim's id
this approach might work because in some
cases as you can see in the diagram
below
the authorization mechanism is
implemented on one micro service this is
very common in modern applications that
the actuation mechanism is one micro
service this micro service might run a
like a framework of ruby on rails and
ruby on rails uses specific library to
pass jsons or to pass the urls
and in this case
this library of ruby on rails might
consider the first id but then the api
endpoint itself that actually fetches
the data from the you know this is after
localization you're already allowed to
access this endpoint
so maybe the logic to access uh to fetch
the data
is using a different library because
it's a different micro service it's a
different framework for example jungle
and then this framework
takes considers the second id
other random tricks if you see an id in
the url try to move it to the request
body if you see an id in the request
body try to move it to the url sometimes
it works
uh if you see a guid try to send a
numeric value as well like integer if
you see like a random long grid just try
to send like
five or six
sometimes companies have support for
both of them and they they implement
different mechanisms to protect against
volatile guid and
id and
one tip that i can give you one of the
best tips they can give you
this can make that can make your life
easier try to focus on ideas in the body
they tend to be more vulnerable than
ideas in their oil
or in the query parameters
let's talk about excessive data exposure
exposure how we can exploit this
vulnerability so excessive data exposure
is one of my favorite vulnerabilities
instead of performing a complex plan
test api is just leak pii by design
let's see how it looks like behind the
scenes
you have bob
you have you use some leading up and
then you see the profile of bob and you
say only only the public data about both
like name and hobbies
but behind the scenes uh you can see an
api call to get slash user 717
and the api response contains all the
public data like name profile picture
but you can also find the address of bob
which is pii what happens many times
developers on the back end the reliable
developers of the front end to filter
out the sensitive data this is a very
bad idea maybe you can you cannot see it
as a user because the developer actually
filter out this data before presenting
it to the ui but if you sniff the api
traffic you can easily expose
this information
so um
it's a good question how to exploit this
vulnerability in apis because you know
it's not very straightforward you just
need to call all the api endpoints and
start taking a look at the responses
so some tips they can give you how to
navigate this maze
would be to understand the hierarchies
between users roles and resources
let's say for example that you access
this api call to get your previous
rights
from this from this response you can
understand that you have the resource of
rights that inside it it has a nested
resource of driver
and then the nested resort driver has a
resource of car
so the ride here does not contain pii
right
and or pii or any other type of
sensitive data because when you talk
about excessive data exposure the goal
here is to
for us as a pentester is to find a
sensitive data
so we see that also the driver does not
contain pii
but the car
the car
resource actually contains the vin of
the vehicle which is pii this is a
unique identifier of a vehicle it
shouldn't be exposed
so let's say that now your goal is to is
to find details about the driver so what
you should do is to find all the
endpoints that expose the driver
resource
so
what you should do is to find more
endpoints that actually access this
information and maybe because it's a
different endpoints there is different
code in the backend that is running and
maybe the developer the developers made
a mistake and returned too much
information like in this case if you
have an option to export right to
uh to a cvs file you can see that
this inform the response from this api
call contains a sensitive data about
information
so you found an api encoder it exposes
ki of a driver
and then
you want to
to move in even
further and to find more information
about the driver so you go and you find
a different endpoint that accesses in
some way like basically it's it's a game
of understanding which endpoints access
which resources
so you you're trying to find
endpoints that access the driver
resource right so you find you say okay
i have an option to report uh to report
a complaint about the driver that did
something illegal on the on the road
so you access the web application to
report driver and you send a complaint
and you hope to see in the response some
descendant of detail details about the
driver
but you don't find anything you suggest
the name is john it's not interesting
but what happens if you replace web to
mobile and you report the driver you
might be able to access the address of
of the driver
and then you might access you you might
find an ad
a driver account and you want to
register your car right just as part of
like creating a new user
as a driver
uh so what you can try to do here is to
register a car and to put the vin of a
different car that you already have from
the diff like from the previous endpoint
this is at the end it belongs to a
different driver
and then these phones actually says this
vin is assigned to a car and you get the
geo id of a different car
um and if you access and then you like
you keep looking at the app as a driver
and you see an api endpoint to fetch the
details of your car
v2 slash car details and the id of the
car
so you can use the id of the car that we
got from the previous api endpoint
to access uh
details about any another car that
belongs to a different user
but the response does not contain
interesting information so we can try to
change it to like maybe v3 and this is a
good tip many times the implementation
of v2 and v1 and v3 are different
and you can see that v3 of a car details
actually exposes the whole object of the
of the user of the driver so this is a
way to get pii like the full name the
last login and even there is a possible
token this is a full account takeover
and this is based on a real example so
this is like the mindset i know it might
be a bit complex but this is the mindset
that is required to find this type of
vulnerability we need to find all the
endpoints to expose the resource that
you potentially want to to exploit or
you want to find excessive data exposure
so it's more about finding more
endpoints than like you know sending
different payloads
um
so let's talk about api predictability
apis are very predictable and we can
leverage this fact as pentesters
in order to
to do interesting stuff
the first one how can we leverage a
predictable nature of rest apis to find
admin endpoints
so
in the case of traditional applications
it was very hard to find admin endpoints
why because you had to guess all this uh
you know endpoint of slash apps slash
admin panel slash user management.spx
and you need to mention the action and
the user id
and this is an endpoint that exposed
only to admins even if the developers
did not check that your user belongs to
the admin group it would be hard for you
as a pentester to find the the endpoint
fortunately in apis it becomes much more
simple apis are very clear and many
times
if you want to find admin endpoints you
can just change the hp method so let's
say that you use the app
as a regular user and you see an api
call to get slash api users user id
you just change the
get to delete and you find an admin
endpoint to delete a user so you found
the path to the endpoint and in many
cases developers don't really validate
that you belong to the admin group and
you can access admin functions
how can we leverage the predictable
nature of rest apis to find hidden
features so
you know many times api we spell secrets
if you saw this api call this is some
right sharing app this is uber and then
the response contains payment option but
you paid only one
only using one credit card but as you
can see the response contains the id of
your credit card inside an array the
first thing i would try to do if i saw
this api response is to try to find the
the payment splitting option because if
there is an array in the response there
is a reason for it there is probably
some option to split the payment and it
might be a very interesting feature
one of the best things i can give you
if you perform a pen test for
applications especially apis
don't focus on the main api endpoints if
you have you know in facebook the main
api endpoints would be to upload a photo
or to leave a comment these endpoints
probably the developers that wrote them
probably invested more time thinking
about security and probably they already
had some like security assessment so
your goal as a pentester is to find the
most niche niche features for example if
you have an option to add christmas
greeting to your profile this is
something that exposes only like you
know for a couple of weeks during the
year uh and nobody actually uses it so
this might be this much more likely to
be vulnerable to vulnerabilities
than like the main endpoints or for
example if you have an option to connect
myspace account probably developers you
know
put less effort to secure this api
endpoint because nobody uses myspace
today and and and the way to find this
hidden endpoint so like it's snitch at
the endpoints is to look for urls in
javascript apk and ipa files and also
it's very important to dig
deep into the
ui in order to find all these features
because every time you find like a new
feature a new button that you know
like it takes time to find this button
behind the scenes there is an api an
interesting api call it is triggered to
a niche api endpoint
how can you leverage the predictable
nature of rest apis to find hidden
versions
uh
so for example if you want to find sub
api you can just take the api call to
all trips with the content type of
applications.json duplicate the api call
and to change it to application
xml and you might be able to find a soap
api
and many times if you have sub-apis and
rest apis and graphql
don't assume that all these apis like
different protocols they usually don't
implement the same security mechanisms
so even if you
found rate limiting when it comes to
rest apis probably the soap apis don't
have it because it's different
configuration and
many times they're more exposed
to find all the endpoints you just can
change the v3 to v1 and might be able to
find a different different endpoint this
is pretty simple and but it's very
helpful to expand attack surface this
way
you can find this presentation these
slides i'll share with you
um
and a few more resources that might be
helpful for you to perform a more
successful pentas for apis is the host
top 10 for apis and i also post a lot of
tips on my personal twitter account and
medium about api security
um i hope you enjoyed the presentation
and let me know if you have any
questions also feel free to ping me on
twitter and linkedin i'm always happy to
discuss api security